welcome everyone this is a kind of
novice giulia tutorial so my plan today
is hopefully we'll get everyone up and
running with Julia and you'll be able to
follow along with this notebook I've
I've put together I'm gonna leave this
up for a couple more minutes as I
introduce myself
and so I'm chase Coleman I'm a PhD
student at NYU Stern and I'm studying
economics I'm also a member of an
open-source economics team called quanti
Khan and so the the standard in
economics is is pretty bad right now in
terms of software development and so
we're trying to teach you know other
academic economists and some new tools
so you know there's people that are as
advanced as us or more advanced but kind
of the the status quo isn't isn't where
we'd like it to be so should I leave
this up for a minute more people still
okay so so yeah so it kind of in both so
I started I came across Julia partially
because of both of these roles as PhD
student and being a member of this
organization quanti Khan in particular
there's another developer on quanti Khan
who who kind of pushed it on me I so I
was kind of Python and you know Helen
high water I wasn't gonna learn anything
else but he kept he kept pestering me
and eventually I said okay I'll try it
for this one class we were doing a
Bayesian estimation class together and
and you know there's there some nice
things about it so hopefully you know
I'm not here to draw people away from
Python than Mathis Mathis I think
there's room for both of them and I mean
I frequently use both languages but
there's some advantages I think that
we'll be able to highlight in this
tutorial okay how is this going
yeah that's a good idea yeah yeah that's
a great question and I should have put
this up there so if you just open up a
jupiter notebook like you normally do
this package dot add I jus Lea this
magic incantation is going to add a
Giulia kernel to your jupiter notebook i
don't know i usually only have one
anaconda installation at a time but
it'll do at least one of them are there
any other questions so so I'm gonna
start skip going ahead and slide so if
you want to get a picture of this or you
could even just go straight here and you
could find this slide in the notebook
yeah I saw a hand up yeah so you won't
be able to open the notebook until you
run it so so you have to open up Julia
and run that and then you'll be able to
open a jupiter notebook and you'll have
an additional colonel
okay so CC 7 7 6 8 pi data DC Julia
that's where all of this information
will be so I told you who I was I guess
one disclaimer I'm not on the Julia
development team so nothing I say is set
in stone this is kind of possibly
incoherent ramblings of someone who who
is fond of Julia and thinks highly of
the Julia group so what's Julia have has
everyone heard of Julia already so it's
this so there's this new ish programming
language I think can I with every year
we can't say new anymore but it's it's
relatively new and it's designed to be
both high level and high performance and
and what do I mean by by these things so
when I say high level I mean it's gonna
look a lot like some mix of python and
matlab so the syntax I think will look
really familiar it's going to have
dynamic types it's gonna help you for
kind of wrap it you'll be able to
rapidly prototype code and Julia just
like you would with Python or MATLAB but
there's this there's this additional
thing so you kind of writing vanilla
python or vanilla MATLAB you'll run into
these problems where you get to an inner
loop of some function and and you have
to go out and you have to write it and
see to get the speed that you need
hypothetically you don't need to do that
with Julie and it's and so I put this
potentially because if you write bad
julia code then Julia won't be able to
do a good job kind of writing code
itself and the compiled code won't be
very fast so it's based on the same
technology have a lot of people here to
use numba so it's based on the same LLVM
technology so it's really good
one thing I kind of I like about Julia
is it helps solve the two language
problem so you look at Hanna the core
Python developers like these guys
writing pandas and numpy a lot of what
they do ends up being in C or C++ so a
lot of julia is written in julia
so modulo like linear algebra and things
and standard packages like that it's
it's written all in julia
and so one red thing so sometimes
naively written code can suffer
performance penalties this is true in
all languages but if you I mean if
you're like really bet if you write
really bad julia code it can be slower
than than other things you would run
into so so this is kind of a warning for
the future so so the three guys in
charge of Julia the cofounders are Jeff
biz Anson Stephan Karpinsky and verall B
Shaw they're all great and I think
everyone should have downloaded the zero
five release and if you have another one
most of this code will still probably
run okay so and the natural first thing
to do anytime you you started with
programming languages is run hello world
so you know this is every so does
everyone have a notebook or should I
wait like two more minutes for people to
get things installed and set up oh I see
so the download speed is a problem okay
well I ran hello world on behalf of
everyone here so hello Julia world
you'll notice in Julia we're using a
println function so that's for print
line they have a print function but it
does kind of the same thing it would do
and see where it just prints things one
after another without a line break
see this this is the Spencer that when I
told you got me into Julia he's kind of
rapidly helping me finish up some plots
that I haven't thought I wanted to show
you guys so thanks Spencer so great so I
think the best way to learn a new
language is to this to do a simple
example so the example that's natural to
me maybe other people have other ones is
just a bisection function so if you
think back to I don't know did we do
this in high school but you have a you
have some kind of a smooth function and
and it crosses zero so on one side of
the of this zero it's negative and on
the other side it's positive and this
algorithm goes like this find a point
exactly in between these two so find
their midpoint and check whether it's
positive or negative and depending on
whether it's positive or negative update
one of the end points and this interval
gets smaller and smaller until you're
close enough to zero so so what do we
have here so we have first to declare a
function you use the word function so
this would be the equivalent of a Python
def then you put the function name and
then you have the function arguments so
everything to the left of the semicolon
is kind of standard argument and
everything to the right would be a key
word so if you wanted to enter these
arguments you'd have to type out max
itter
or tall so you set default values just
like you would in Python with just
equals the number and then this is maybe
a bit different so so it's actually so
putting this here isn't necessary but
what it does is it tells it tells the
julia compiler that f is a function and
so you actually kind of you don't get a
performance gain for this it's in my
mind it serves as a document as
documentation to yourself about what
types you want things to do and I don't
want people passing an F that isn't a
function to my bisect function
because that's the function we want to
find the zero of so so it gives you a
chance to kind of enforce the types that
you want to come into the function and
so you have to pool and packing this is
if you've done C you'll recognize this
is a ternary operator so the way to read
that is if F times B is greater than
zero which means that F of a and F of B
are either both negative or both
positive then raise an error because to
find the zero we need them to be on
different sides of the zero so the way
we raise an error is just error with a
message and then so yeah so it reads so
if that thing is true then do this first
part raise the error or else do nothing
so this this is just question mark and
colon defines the ternary yeah yeah
that's cut off yeah there's just there's
an NG at the end it just disappeared
they're invisible I like that so so then
a for loop how many people I've had the
displeasure of writing that lab so kind
of a lot of us so you'll notice I don't
know I don't I don't totally hate this
but they have end statements so notice
with this for loop so I don't need the
indentation but Anna Python has given me
these good habits of indenting all of my
loops and my blocks and making my code
readable but I don't need it the way it
reads that is for I equals 1 and 1 colon
Mac sitter is just a range variable like
it would be in Python and then I have to
end my for loop with an end state with
an end statement so here's another
ternary operator and then here's an
if-else statement notice it also has an
end and then it raises an error message
if it fails to converge
yeah go ahead exactly it's just the
normal if yeah I think they're
interchangeable there's there's also
another they use I think some people
aren't fans of it but in case you ever
come across it you could do some you
know let me type it and then I'll talk
so this end and is like an and statement
and so Julia evaluates first the
left-hand side of code and so if it
evaluates to true then it goes to check
the other side but we've used that other
side to return something instead of to
evaluate another conditional I saw
another hand yeah yeah of course uh-huh
yes exactly so the semicolon is it's
splitting kind of your normal function
arguments that you have to supply every
time unless they have a default value
and keyword arguments so I actually I I
think but don't quote me on it I think
all of your keyword arguments have to
have a default value and so I so if I
wanted to call these I'll do an example
of it in a second if I wanted to call
these it would be max it equals and tall
equals if I wanted to change it yeah
function is a type so it can so you can
use these for any type so we could
impose for example these are float64 s
by doing something like that so any type
that julia recognizes you can you can
specify that you'd like that argument to
be of that type yeah that's embarrassing
I know no it's not at all it it'll
totally ignore the whitespace but kind
of my moral rounding so it does yeah so
it cares about new lines you can do the
MATLAB e colon thing so I think if we
did that it would treat it as the same
but I don't like that
yeah
No yeah it'll do the same thing so when
we get to i Julie if you don't want it
to display something you should put
extend my colon after it okay so this is
like the syntax overview served ask
questions I'm going to assume everyone's
experts in five minutes yeah yeah so
this matches with the function key word
exactly right
okay oh yeah that's a right so we want
it so this is just a little trick if it
ever returns something inside the
for-loop it'll finish and if not then we
know we went past our maximum iteration
but that brings up another point this
dollar sign this is string interpolation
so what this will do is it'll look for
the variable max itter which is 500 and
it'll say fail when it prints it'll
print failed to converge in 500
iterations thank you that was something
I wanted to mention so that's
okay how's it coming on the downloads
slow okay oh that's a that's unfortunate
okay so so we can do that so the other
thing you can do is you can do shorthand
function definitions so this f of x
equals x cubed basically just translates
to function x return x cubed and so this
is this is a normal function and if you
wanted to do an anonymous function it
would look like that so Julie knows
about both of those I don't think I ran
this code so let me go back and run this
way to have things that work
and lo and behold the bisect with both
the normal functions I am on a leash and
the anonymous function they both produce
the same result
yay okay so just like in Python you can
do comprehensions julia doesn't have a
list type so this is this would be an
array comprehension instead of a list
comprehension but it looks the same and
acts exactly the same oh yeah that's
nice huh so Julia accepts Unicode so if
you've ever typed latex
if you type slash P I so you'll notice
Julia actually knows what pi is and
what's the one they use for the golden
number Phi no I could guess it but I
don't remember so they have a couple of
these mathematical where standard
symbols programmed in but you can also
define you can define your variables as
these things so you can say Row 1 is
equal to if you want to get really
obnoxious I think you can even do like
superscripts and subscripts it can get
really elaborate but it's gonna be text
no I there's one way to check
sorry this is a
sorry so I have to put this down for a
minute to type so X
yeah so so it it recognizes it as a
variable nada and then try x-squared no
that's right
yeah so it's not gonna see it so it's
defining these things as if they were
latex variables basically not
necessarily so we're gonna talk about
they have the new so this is this is
actually kind of a cool thing so they
they've been working on what they're
calling loop fusion so in numpy and I
think num next
and um expr nameks they have the weight
I think that gets around this but
they're they're fusing loops so when you
numpy when you do NP cosine n pi sine of
an array it creates a temporary which is
NP sign and then evaluates and P cosine
of that and so it creates that some
temporaries in between so they're
working on a new feature where it will
be smart enough to fuse those together
so it'll compute every element of this
array as cosine of sine of an element
instead of creating the temporary in
between
so I don't know a whole lot about that
I'm not a computer scientist but it
sounds cool
okay so comprehensions so here's just
some standard broadcasting that you can
do so what are these we can do element
wise operations just like you would a
MATLAB with dot divide and dot times
matrix multiplication is just times you
can do solve ax equals B like you can in
MATLAB with the backslash and then this
broad cap I mean so this broadcast trick
is worth noting so what it did is it
took a column vector and then added it
to a row vector and the output was a two
by three so it's a two column plus a
three row and it mert it put those
together it knows the dot plus should
make things work the right way so that's
this one right here so yeah
so yeah so you notice it took that two
and the three and just made them into a
two by three so you can do neat
broadcasting tricks you can do that in
an umpire too so that's it's not
revolutionary but it's good to know when
you come across it
okay so this is the thing I was just
talking about the this is doing the loop
fusions so if you want the actual
details I have a link where they have
kind of a long discussion about what's
happening and why they're doing it at
first I actually kind of disliked the
syntax so if you remember we defined a
function f and we forced X to be a float
64 and then just in this last slide
okay so somewhere we defined X to be a
vector here we go so it's a it's all of
the elements from 0 to 2pi with 50
spaced in between and so this function
shouldn't know how to do this but they
they take this same dot notation for the
broadcasting that's why I put that in
the last slide so if you do the function
dot and then the argument it converts
your scalar function into a vectorized
function and this is I think this is
what they're taking advantage of to do
these loop fusions so if we had cosine
dot sine dot X
so actually that's I think will or in
some benchmarks in a second but
I must not have ensign code
oh it has an INT oh that's right no I
was confused I didn't think it would
have any integers thank you for that
okay so now it works so so we'll look
when I load up the benchmark tools
remind me to to benchmark the cosine dot
sine dot of X and we'll we'll see that
it ends up allocating a lot less memory
I think if you don't add the dots it has
it does something like 300,000
allocations if we for some big X and if
you do it without it only does as many
elements as are in the vector I think so
it's cool
and so you can do you can call C and
Fortran pretty easily so all this is is
C call as a function and that helps
Julianne know how to go call C so we go
get the math library and we want the log
function and the output is going to be a
float and the input is going to be a
float and we want to evaluate it at 1 so
that makes calling C easy so this is why
they were able to wrap a lot of these
linear algebra packages so nicely so you
look at this Julia
has anyone written Lisp so not very many
people so I think it's kind of like a
mind-blowing experience because you're
writing you can use these meta
programming where you're writing code
that writes code and so that's a so
these guys actually I think skipped a
lot of the steps that they otherwise
would have had to do because they just
said for every function do this same
type of thing and so they wrote code
that wrote code to wrap the la pack and
Blas
okay how's the download
slowly coming your what excellent so so
python is an object-oriented to this
isn't this isn't going to be
revolutionary for a lot of people here
but everything in julia has a type and
more than that there's there's going to
be a hierarchy of types and you can
think about that just as like a
parent-child relation in terms of
classes or this abstract base classes or
you can't define thing or you can't
define an instance of it but it's there
as an organization tool so so we're
gonna have the same type of things so
this is a I think a good example if I
can get my I use the mouse okay so so
the numbers in in Julia or are organized
like this so at the top there's a type
and so what they call them is they call
these abstract types so you can never
have an instance of it but there are
there are other types that are subtypes
of that in some sense and so you have so
what do you have so you have at the top
numbers and then you have either complex
which are type that you can actually
implement and real which is another
abstract type so the end of each of
these arrows will be one of the types
that you can actually create an instance
of and everything in between is going to
be an abstract type so you go from
number to real and then you can split
things up into integer irrational or
rational then notice boolean's are just
going to be a number type so they're
gonna get all of the same operations
from numbers and we'll talk about why
they have signed and unsigned integers
etc so this is so when you're thinking
about julia types this is the kind of
thing you want to have in your mind and
then at the top so this would be kind of
at the very top so beyond number is
something they call any and so what the
so any is is bad news because it means
that the compiler can't get any
information about what you're trying to
do so so if you if you try to add two
numbers and it knows that a method
exists for adding integers it's going to
be able to infer a lot of information
from
you're giving in so so here's some some
types so 1.0 is gonna be a float 64 1 is
6 into 64 boolean note the lowercase T
and lowercase F coming from Python you
have strings you can tell it that you
want an INT 8 instead of an int 64 and
then you can have a raise so so we'll
talk about these in a minute but inside
this array notice it's telling you some
extra stuff about it it says not only is
this an array but this array has types
of float64 and one dimension and so
these are going to be called type
parameters
and it's great so so here's what I think
is one of like the really exciting
things about Julius of slating this is
new so it's called they call it multiple
dispatch so in an object-oriented
language like Python or Java everything
by nature is single dispatch and what
does that mean as it means when you have
a class you have a bunch of function of
methods that are specialized on the
first argument of that function which is
the class itself so you can you pass all
of the class methods self and Julia
they're gonna take that a step further
and functions are going to specialize on
all of the arguments so to understand
let's let's see some examples I've
written my dumb function MDF for short
so remember I said at the very top of
this hierarchy is the type in E so the
first thing we'll do is we're going to
define a method for this my dumb
function that takes two of anything and
this is it's going to work its way back
and this will basic this will act as a
fallback method so all this function is
going to do is it's going to print the
type of a and the type of B and then
return nothing
so tells us the type of a and B are in
64's in this case and then the type of a
is a function and the type of B here is
irrational so so what if we might want
this my dumb function to do something a
bit different so now let's say we want
to specialize my dumb function so that
when it sees a number in the A or B
argument we want it to tell us that a is
a number or B is a number or if both of
them are numbers ha we're both numbers
so if we run this
and so remember these are the same
functions we've run previous so these
are the same calls that we've run
previously but we've now defined some
new methods so what Julia is doing is it
sees that both of these are numbers
which is more specific than any and so
it knows to refer to this method where
they're both numbers and when a or b are
numbers it knows to refer to these other
two methods so notice it's specializing
on each of the types of the arguments so
even though these both have one function
and one number the order matters so this
is you can do some really cool things
with this and we'll talk about some
examples but there's a preview so I'm an
economist and what economists do is
solve models and pretend it's the real
world and and so when you when you have
these you know models that are
simplifications of the real world you
have to simulate them but but you write
this boilerplate code like I can't tell
you the number of times I've written
kind of a boilerplate code for
simulating a model and then it's like
really easy you just thought you need to
have like a next function to tell you
what next period is going to look like
and given a bunch of information today
so so this is going to allow you so you
can have like an abstract model at the
type and then you can have different
instances of this model and they can all
refer to certain functions that are
going to be that you don't need any more
information other than it's a model so
so this this type of thing I think is
really useful when for me as a model
builder so now we'll talk about type of
parameters so great so so I told you we
have this extra information and this is
just going to allow the compiler to
specialize even more so how is it going
to do that so now we have my dump
function again and what do we have so
the new thing here are these curly
brackets so so we're making our way you
may or may not notice but we're making
our way down this down this hierarchy so
we had any which is above number and
then we defined some functions that are
based on number and now we're going to
define some functions that are based on
abstract float and integer and so these
functions are gonna get more and more
specialized and so what are we going to
do so we're going to say if you pass us
so so this T so you can only use : : to
tell a type when it can actually be
instantiated I mean it can be created
and so if you want it to be a subset of
a larger of a larger type you use the
caret and : and so what we say is that
there's some type T which is an instance
of abstract float so it's either float
16 float 32 or float 64 and if we if we
call my dumb function with a and B that
are vectors with elements of type T so
this is going to force them to be the
same so that's a good exam to be the
same then it's going to say a and B are
vectors with some kind of float and in
particular let's change this to with the
same kind of float
and then we can do the same thing this
is exactly equivalent except with the
abstract entity type so if we define
these and then then run this notice it
recognizes that both of these start with
the same type of float but what happens
if we change does it and so if I change
this to float 32 so all this is going to
do is it's going to create a vector of
ones that with type float 32 instead of
float 64 which is the default does
anyone have a guess at what the first
one's going to tell us now
yeah it's gonna tell us some kind of
float
so so notice this function forces it to
be not only some kind of float but the
same kind of float so this saw float32
and float64 and they said I don't know
what to do with vectors that have
different types so it walked its way
back all the way to the first method
which was any and any this is so this is
kind of cool yeah go ahead
yeah because these aren't because these
aren't even numbers these are vectors of
numbers and it differentiates between
those two things yeah yeah no siree it
totally can so you're not entirely wrong
but but it's gonna be able it's going to
be able to do some useful things and one
of so I kind of talked of a Glee about
having these multiple types of models
and then you might have like what if I
wanted to write a function called
published paper and published paper
paper took a model and a question and
then we needed us we need a solve method
for each model because models differ
enough that you have to solve them a bit
differently so you could write kind of
the general paper function and then it's
gonna dispatch when it gets to the solve
question function and that will depend
on the salt on the model and the
question type does that make sense
great notice it's it's like it's a bit
so you can run into these you can run
into libraries and if you're not careful
it can it can get really messy really
quickly and you can get things or you
have like a whole file like 500 lines
long that defines the same function over
and over again yeah so it's like and
then you you spend your time trying to
figure out which one you want so I think
probably in response to something like
this they defined so the at sign is an
example of the meta programming so it's
going to write a piece of code but app
so this when you type at which MDF
one's and three so what so what are we
saying we want this at which says which
of the methods are you calling when you
try and refer to this and so it says I'm
trying to call the method that takes two
arrays of integers that you defined in
your input 25 which was just right here
so when you have a file it will tell you
like a line number and stuff and you can
have it you can set it up to where if
you have an editor set and Julia if you
type edit this it'll open it up in a
text in your text editor and take you
straight to that line and I think that's
exactly because it can get really messy
when you're dealing with kind of a bunch
of methods that do similar things but on
different types yeah yeah
how far yeah so this one is so note this
no so number remember is that the open
is that the top of this hierarchy oh
these two this or the difference between
these two yeah so this is when it says
number it's only going to be a scalar so
we could define another method that took
a vector of numbers and have that be a
default fallback for anything that was a
vector of numbers oh just the one line
yes yeah yeah yeah that's just shorthand
so that was I put it up on a slide
earlier but just kind of skipped past it
so if you write F of arguments equals
something this turns it it's an actual
function not an anonymous function or
anything that's yeah thank you yeah
in the order of the tree right the type
tree I saw hand go up and down somewhere
over here no yeah so it walks it walks
its way up the type tree
yeah so so you can actually you can
actually put in like sign as a as a type
signed yeah yeah yeah anything in that
in that hierarchy is things that you can
don't actually call a type yeah you can
actually use that's right so anything in
this hierarchy can be used as a as a
type for for this tree that it's going
to search through in the multiple
dispatch yeah and so the other thing I
guess to note is similar to number the
first time you call one of these
functions it compiles its first case of
it so this is so we have this function
MDF any any and we've called it with a
couple of different things if we
actually if we ask Julia if we say
methods MDF it's going to be it's going
to tell us all of the methods its
compiled so notice this really this
could be an infinite number of methods
speaking if we call the function each
time but it doesn't Julia doesn't know
about them until they've run for the
first time yeah it still waits just in
time yeah
yeah you can do you can ahead of time
compile Julia but for the most part it's
fine to run it just in time yes so you
can see because there's a package called
PI call
and so from Julia you can actually
access every package in in Python so
they have some examples I'll try and do
an example when we get towards the end
and talk about packages if this would be
so using PI call brings in this package
PI call and then we can import the
Python math library and then we can
evaluate math dot sine of math dot pi
minus sine of pi/4 which is just the
julia so this is subtracting the python
evaluation and the Julia valuation and
vice versa yeah well I don't know how if
you can call Julia from Python yet I
don't think it's so because you can
compile Julia I'm guessing you could
work your way into it but I don't think
a lot of people have done it yet
okay yeah so this this is sometimes
useful when you when you're trying to
figure out what you actually want to do
so type parameter so we can specialize
using those so yeah so user types I
think kind of the thing that so the Zen
of Python I always think of things as
honking good ideas so kind of building
your own types and julia is a honking
good idea so you say so you should like
not only do this but you should do this
frequently they have a couple of gotchas
about where you should specialize on
abstract types vers concrete types but
they talked about these in the
performance tips so I put a link here
but you're not it's this isn't going to
cause kind of massive performance issues
it's just a heads up so great so so we
could define our own type we could
define a two dimensional point that has
values x and y so what does this mean so
remember so now T just like when we had
our functions is going to be a type
parameter and so all we're enforcing
here is we're enforcing that x and y
have the same type and then so what do
we do we can define two points point
point a is in string space two
dimensional string space whatever that
looks like and then point B is in a two
dimensional real numbers so floats to be
exactly yes and so notice now when we
look at the type of a and B it's
actually changed that T to be a string
or a float so at this point Julia knows
that one is a point with type string
inside and the other is a point with
types float inside and it knows that
these two types are different
so what could we do we could define an
addition function so when you define
functions on top of base functions like
addition you have to do base dot in
front of it and then because plus is a
symbol you have to put a colon that's
just a syntactic whatever so but what do
we do is we want to do we want to
defined an addition for points that have
type parameter number so we don't want
to be able to add any type except points
with numbers I don't look that's just uh
I don't know God's law and so so what do
we have is we have a point to D and we
say how do you add the two points you
add their x-values you add their
y-values and you return a new point so
we can do a plus a but remember a was
our point that had strings so it says I
don't know what plus looks like when you
do strings but when we do a b plus b b
was just 1.0 1.0 it produces 2.0 2.0 so
so we can do this so then you know you
think what are the possible uses of this
is this is this worth the trouble and
this is what i was saying you know we
can think about defining kind of larger
types and then we can define something
similar so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna find two laws of motion LOM one is
going to be a quadratic law of motion so
if anyone likes kind of these chaotic
processes this is just going to be a
quadratic chaos process and then we're
gonna do just an affine law of motion as
well and so what are these going to look
like the first one the quadratic will
have a parameter lambda that I'm forcing
to be a float and this is defining like
a call method so it says whenever we try
and call this type what we want it to
evaluate is m dot lambda times x times 1
minus X and then we do something similar
for the affine or we do alpha plus beta
sex so run that so now we can define a
simulate function just like I said and
notice we're defining it on the abstract
law of motion and both of these things
were subtypes of the abstract law of
motion so quadratic law of motion and a
fine law of motion are both subtypes of
this abstract type abstract law of
motion and so how are we going to
simulate it we just want to get the last
value so for 1/2 T just keep evaluating
this thing and storing it in X and then
spit out X at the end
there so I accidentally ran it twice so
it was warning me that I've overwritten
my own method but so now notice when we
call simulate we have to simulate
functions if we ask it for methods
simulate
it's going to tell us that oh there so
there's two methods one with the tea and
one without the tea and the reason it
doesn't say M quadratic law of motion
and M affine law of motion is because we
just have the abstract type there okay
so we're going to use these later and
we're going to draw a pretty graph then
I was creating in the last five minutes
before the tutorial yeah go ahead
you do so the cap T is in a keyword
argument it's an argument that has a
default value so when I when I called it
notice I didn't specify anything here
but if I put 500 it would have simulated
this one for longer than the other one
yeah so it can have a default value so
that's what this is doing it says this
function that doesn't have cap t just
calls out to this function with its
default value
okay so so that's kind of the ideas main
ideas behind Julia you have kind of this
this type system that allows you to do
multiple dispatch in this multiple
dispatch helps the compiler in some ways
so so they actually they ship a package
system with Julia and it's just a get
based system there's two types of
packages that you can have so yeah so
there's gonna be a bunch of package
manager commands and they're all inside
of your base julia already and they'll
be referenced by PKG command so you can
have registered packages so these are
mature packages that have a sense of
approval so there's some so there's some
guys that keep a big file of all of the
registered packages and they kind of
they keep track of when they update and
so these are packages that people have
approved and then unregistered are kind
of things a lot of people have written
offhand or are progressing towards
becoming registered you have to install
these packages a bit differently so if
you run package add forward dif forward
diff is a is a package that does your
derivatives and it does it a number of
different ways including doing kind of
this automatic differentiation which i
think is really cool and then if you
want an unregistered package you'd use
package clone and then give it an HTTP
GET repository so if we do this it'll
probably tell me I don't need to add
anything for forward diff and then it's
going to add this very incomplete and
crappy package I've put together and
never finished so once that finishes oh
gosh this is probably the Internet huh
so once this finishes so it added these
that went in cloned this repository and
pulled it in you'll want to run this
next line to make sure that you never
see that code again um so great so so
that's how you add and remove packages
so you add them in a slightly different
way using package add and
catch clone and then you remove them the
same way just packaged RM and then if
you want to update to the most recent
versions of all of your package just you
do this
PKG update and what it'll go through is
it'll get a list of all of the versions
of the packages you have then it'll
compare it with the online version of
all of them listed packages and it'll
look for differences and then it'll
fast-forward the things that need to be
moved forward
so using packages so if we wanted to use
this forward diff package then we can
see everything in its namespace using
just this tab completion so forward diff
dot and this tells us everything that
for diff has inside of it some of the
things are useful other things aren't so
this this will show you literally
everything packages can choose to export
subsets of this and that walk when you
do using forward difficult and your
julian namespace actually i looked and i
think this package takes a stand that
they don't want to export anything that
you don't want and so they don't export
anything so so if i wanted to do use
this to differentiate the function
cosine of x x plus two times x squared
minus five x i could use in this
automatic differentiation it has and and
compute the derivative of that function
at one
okay so plotting packages it's still
kind of a dog bite or a battlefield out
here so there's and so this isn't even
completely so I think like three or four
more that are serious competitors so
luckily there's a guy Tom Bree laughs so
he's put together instead it's crazy to
have this many people this many plotting
packages and he's written what he calls
plots and it gives you access to
whichever of the backends you want
conditional on him deciding to support
them so right that's exactly right it's
a have you seen that xkcd comic where
you know there's fourteen competing
standards we should create one that
unifies all of them you know five months
later there's fifteen comedic exceeding
standards so no so I think it's I think
it's a bit better than that because he
only his only goal is to be an API and
this API is is going to be the same
across all of the packages and he's done
like a like top notch documentation like
you know hats off to him every time I
start something I never get to the
documentation and he's done a really
good job with it
so so what we're gonna do is we're going
to use plots and we're going to create
the same plot with two different
backends so notice the first one we're
going to use is plot Lee if people seen
plot Lee you can use it in Python - it's
a it's a it's a pretty slick javascript
library so
it's JavaScript so we can interact with
it yay so but if instead we wanted to
use matplotlib because we like
matplotlib this is the python conference
so we could use matplotlib to do
something similar the first so the first
plot with most of these takes a long
time because it's compiling a bunch of
different functions but there we go
so that should look familiar except I
think you've changed some of the
defaults well it's still it's like not
the same right like the ugly the ugly
settings are like home so now we could
come so remember we had this this
quadratic law of motion and we could
create a bifurcation graph yay so so I
actually said so I chose PI plot for
this one specifically because plotly
passes everything around as a JSON and
there's something like 250,000 points on
this so it takes plotly a little bit to
to make something like that and we can
also okay so this one will take a minute
if you have questions now is a good time
to ask but we're gonna we're going to
make an animation using matplotlib
really yep really it's like a minute
but the good thing I guess is let me see
if it'll run and go back while it's
running so the nice thing is if we
wanted to use any of these other
backends so if we didn't want to make
this with pipe lot but we wanted to make
it with one of the other backends that
wasn't plotly and to not pass around
that JSON then all we would have to do
is change which of the backends we're
using I submitted a an issue this
afternoon for Unicode plots it was
giving me Stack Overflow okay sounds
like it's almost done what it does not
support bouquet
you could you could talk them into it
submit a pull request though
so
we have a little 3-dimensional gift so
any of the plotting packages that submit
that support both animations and a three
dimensional plots would be able to make
this plot and it's nice because you have
this what they could have this unified
API to interact with all of them so now
let me restart my kernel real quick so
this was my friend Spencer in the last
minute he said plotly can do animations
too and he really wanted me to to get
this in so so I agreed and it's a it's a
nice plot
so it's our same bifurcation graph but
now animated do it again so so I guess
making the making the JSON is one at a
time and then pushing all the
information into the graph was a lot
faster than doing it all at once and so
his workaround was its own nice plot
okay
so performance gotchas so this was
hopefully this will catch some of the
mistakes you might make without
otherwise being aware of them so they
have this path to gauge benchmark tools
it does what you would think it would do
it has tools to do benchmarking so the
first is the first thing to be aware of
is you want to make sure your functions
are type stable so once you define a
variable you don't want the function
thinking it might change types so what I
have here is this first function notice
total starts as an integer and then when
we're doing plus equal inside this loop
it's trying to add it's trying to turn
it into a float so this is going to
prevent Giulia from knowing whether it's
an integer or a float and then when we
use it as a float I'm sure everyone can
guess kind of the outcome of this so
what we're doing is we're just going to
sum up kind of 10 million numbers and
it's gonna tell us some information
about that great so and the average time
was about 70 milliseconds notice it did
no allocations that's really good and
didn't take up any memory so now what
happens when we do this next one so this
is doing the exact same thing but
remember there is this type in stability
up front where it wasn't sure whether
total was going to be an integer or a
float and when this finishes we'll
notice yeah so we'll notice some
different things so it's about
three times is slow and about 10% of the
time it's hanging out in the garbage
collector so it does automatic garbage
collection notice how many allocations
that needed so everyone remember how
many the first example needed zero
laughing this one needed how many is
that like thirty million yeah so thirty
million and it took up about four
hundred fifty seven megabytes so type
stability is a big deal one way that you
can check this is they have these macros
that allow you to kind of introspect the
types and it puts a list of variables up
front so notice this was the stable one
and it says total float 64 and then if
we come to this next version of it it
says total is any so it worked its way
all the way back to the top and it just
said I don't I don't know what to do
with this and you can also actually a
lot of times another indicator is how
long the actual ll I think this code
gets turned into LLVM but this code you
can look at the LLVM if you want they
don't always advise doing so so this is
a relatively short function but if we
come to this next one and look at the
LLVM
it gets a lot longer so that's not kind
of 100% always true but generally if
it's producing short LLVM code it'll be
faster and then it produces short LLVM
code when it can refer things about the
types the other is yeah go ahead yeah
is that is that ever sort of like a
comedy limited list of specific types or
is it just like one type or any I guess
some to suit sometimes so so I don't
know a lot about the insides of the
compiler I think you can have it where
it narrows it down
I don't know 100% for sure okay
yeah I only ask because it says any
instead of instead of int or yeah or
float or something like that or vo yeah
yeah say so the question is why does it
marked all the way to the top to any
when maybe it could get away with going
only to real yeah yes I don't okay so I
don't know if there's sure people can
answer that question but I can't thank
you yeah
what
so any is where it automatically goes so
this is similar to his question I don't
I don't know whether the compiler can
narrow it down to smaller lists of types
so it's like maybe if you had an 8 and
into 16 whether it would be able to do
something different than in this case it
had a float 64 and 64 and it went all
the way up so I don't I don't know for
sure right so it wants to be as careful
as possible so that's that's one of the
things so kind of if it has any
uncertainty about something it goes back
as far as it needs to to feel safe and
so I don't know whether that means it
goes all the way to any or whether
sometimes you can get away with stopping
in between
great so the other thing that you might
you care about in terms of performance
is and Julia memory is stored column
wise instead of row wise so this matters
a lot because most of us are Python
programmers and so in Python memory is
stored column wise so we can do another
simple example so what do we have we
have just a function that sums
everything inside of a matrix and one of
them goes down the columns and one of
them goes across the rows so we'll make
this thing 10,000 by 10,000 and then
we'll run both of these benchmarks and
and look at what it does
great so this one one allocation
took 16 bytes about 90 milliseconds
spoiler alert this one's going to take a
little longer so this one took about 350
milliseconds still only need one
allocation because everything was type
stable so it's not having to do these
crazy you know checking between types or
making sure it infers the type every
time but it's slower so you can so you
can actually see so this one was about a
factor of 3 the other was a factor of 3
so if you make both those mistakes at
once you can easily get yourself to a
factor of 10 so so these I think are the
simplest performance tips that you might
be able to get and then these were
things I had time for I think I have 5
minutes so I have 5 minutes for quest
did people get it installed I guess
that's good so so yeah that was the
question if you guys have questions I'm
happy to answer some questions but I
don't have anything else to say except
thanks for coming today thank you -
Julia contributors everywhere that made
this talk possible and the Jupiter team
and then thanks to the PI data
organizers and sponsors